I'm Brian Fry and I'm the committee chair with Troop and Crew 212 in North Glen Colorado.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me
And now the old scoutmaster.
This week I heard from an old pal and a backer,
longtime listener and reader, Bill McFarland, who is with Troop 8 up in Pittsfield, Massachusetts,
And Bill remarked that Einstein- you know Albert Einstein, the guy with the hair right-
He defined insanity as doing the same thing over and over again and expecting different
results. But Bill disagrees, And when he pointed this out I had to agree with Bill.
That definition of doing the same thing over and over again,
expecting different results, That's that's not insane, That's being a scoutmaster.
Maybe maybe they're both the same thing, I don't know.
Hey everybody, this is podcast number 240. Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green. Well, let's see, looking in the
mailbag this week. a post on the blog last week talked about true north or magnetic north
And I was using a metaphor to describe the difference between the two. And yeah, you go read
the post: true north or magnetic north. Heard from Tim Roekman, who is a troop committee chair
with Troop 142 in Wauwatosa, Wisconsin, who really liked the post. Todd Marrhold
checked in with us on Facebook, said he liked that too. So yeah, check it out. true north
or magnetic north at scoutmastercgcom We heard from Marilyn Gross who is with Troop
391 in Michigan, said thank you for the education You provide so many scouts. You're creating a
positive tropic cascade effect on scouts and consequently our world. Your efforts are
appreciated. Well, thank you so much, Marilyn. Thank you for your kind words. The tropic
cascade- Hey, we heard a little bit about that last week. It's a post on the scoutmastercgcom
And it was the subject of our scoutmaster minute in podcast number 239.. Mike Menager,
who's a scoutmastercgcom backer- He was our backer intro for podcast 239. And Mike said:
keep the good work and the bad jokes coming. You know that might be like the subtitle to the
whole thing, Kind of the tagline: right, Good work and bad jokes, But thanks, Thanks so much, Mike.
Chris Simone is the scoutmaster of Troop 71 in Plandum, New York. I shared your scoutmaster
minute on tropic cascades and the scout law the other night Seemed to be well taken. Thanks for
that And thank you, Chris, for letting me know. I sure appreciate it. Michael Hardy in
Sebastopol, California, also a scoutmastercgcom backer, said your resources, thoughts and podcasts
are appreciated out here in the Redwood Empire Council. I recommended your site to other scouting
friends. Your ideas give us a ray of hope as to how scouting could and ought to be.
Thanks for the chance to support your endeavors Well. thank you, Michael,
Really appreciate your help, And we're going to talk about how everybody can become a backer in
just a moment. Steve Mahoney sent me this message He said: I became an assistant scoutmaster
about seven months ago, and good on your for that, Steve. It didn't take me long to realize that the
troop I was working with didn't really kind of understand the patrol method and they weren't
really applying it. A lot of things were as they are in many troops. Steve, This is how our troop
does it, This is how we've always done it, and never really been examined as to why we're doing
it that way. The troop was on its third scoutmaster in its 30 year history, And I know that
history because I am one of the weeblos that crossed over into the troop 29 years ago. I thought about
writing and asking for your advice about how to change things, But I realized, having listened to
your podcast for the last four years, I already knew what needed to happen. It just wasn't
going to be as easy as I would like. So things are improving. After six months we finally had
elections for senior patrol leaders and patrol leaders. Scouts now know which patrol they're
in- Well, most of them anyway- and they're getting the idea that they can do things.
I'm leading the introduction to outdoor leadership skills course soon And, being an Eagle Scout,
I'm finding that instructing the outdoor skills are the easy part. I can see how the patrol method
is in the curriculum for this course, but it could be missed as just one way of doing things.
The folks in my course won't be able to miss it. Thanks for the dedication, insights and
words of wisdom. Well, thank you, Steve. I'm glad that you're finding all of this useful.
Also heard from our old pal, Hab Butler, who said: I love reading your stuff helps keep me focused
on the individual scout, on the kids. And yeah, well, I try. I do try, Hab. That's the point
And I'm glad that it's getting through Well. this past week on the blog I mentioned the
post about True North or Magnetic North already. There's another post this week about the
origins of the patrol system. understanding how the patrol system originated really
does help inspire you in its application. So make sure to check that out. And in BP's blog-
Baden Powell's blog- this week had a thought from him that goes back to 1914. And it's very
simply titled: Don't an interesting thought from BP. just a couple of sentences, but a very
interesting thought, So do make sure to check that out too. Now, if you're a regular reader
and listener, if all the information and the ideas that we're offering have helped you,
you can return the favor by making a one time contribution and become a scoutmastercgcom
backer. The funds we get from backers go towards the expenses of producing and publishing the
blog posts, the podcast, making the videos, all this stuff that have turned out to be a valuable
resource, And they're accessible for scouts all over the world. It's an easy thing to do.
Go to scoutmastercgcom and click the support link. You'll see all the way. at the top of the
page You can choose any level of support. Some of them entitle you to premiums like autograph
copies of my books. I want to take a moment to personally thank Michael Hardy, Andy Dahmert
and Jody Ammons, who signed on as backers since our last podcast. Thank you so very much. I really
do appreciate it. You're the folks that make it possible. If you're interested in becoming
a backer, go to scoutmastercgcom. Look for the support link at the top of the page
and you'll find out just how to do that. For the remainder of this podcast I'm answering
email questions. and boy, we've had a lot of email questions lately And there are plenty
to go through today. so let's get started, shall we?
Now you've got your trucker's hitch
Email. that is, folks. And here's an answer to one of your emails
Now. over this past week, since podcast 239, I've received several emails asking about a question
that we answered on last week's podcast about requiring or expecting scouts to request a border
review. Apparently, from the emails that I've received over the past week, this is a pretty
widespread practice: Requiring scouts to request a border review before you begin, before the
border review is set up for them, or expecting that they're going to request a border review.
So I want to take a little time to talk through this in a little more detail. If you open up the
Guide to Advancement and you look at Pencils Ready, here we go, Section 8.0.0.2, the Guide to
Advancement says scoutmasters or councils or districts- in the case of the Eagle Scout Rank,
for example- do not have the authority to expect a boy to request or organize.
So let's make sure we understand exactly what's being said. Do not have the authority to expect
a boy to request or organize a border review, or to defer to him or to ask him to perform.